luggage yeah howdy bracket very good a
lot of clay huge walls on both sides of
you at all times describe it sand rock
so it's very flat and it's covered in
sea grass color red sandstone it's very
green very gray and red the best earth
colors possible on a nice sunny day
everything just kind of glows and just
the colors come on that the light
doesn't even have to hit them perfectly
for it to look like the cliffs are on
fire they're so red you took Dagobah
from Star Wars the terrain is to simply
make it except it's gonna be a little
bit cleaner it's like a Midwestern
desert pretty much the quietest place
you could ever come places that feel
like rainforests and everything is
covered in moss 4030 walls on either
side of us but then you get up higher
and there's these jagged peaks and the
steepness we're all dwarfed in these
huge trees and that's all you know
that's all you hear the way the clouds
sit on the mountains I absolutely love
but when you come here it's huge trees
yeah hoodoos which is kind of what
they're famous for which is these
pillars of rock Skagit nice is the kind
of rock geology we're inside a crater of
a volcano the Joshua tree itself got a
lot of Douglas fir trees chunky trees
and bulbous cliffs that are not on this
scale anywhere else in the world when
you stand next to it you were just like
so microscopic compared to that that's
an assay it didn't mention the glaciers
over 300 glaciers hundreds and hundreds
of lakes a lot of water it's just a big
hole in the ground full of water how
clean the water is how deep the lake is
it's much more than that it's one of the
clearest lakes in the world the air is
really crisp yeah so crisp not sunny I
would call it a city but it had Sun
yesterday I like burns our nostrils are
from air is released
hailing smoke all day a high heat wind
it's just kind of it's different unique
little weird feeling Hugh apparently
they're also crocodiles down by the
river
different types of animals that I've
never seen before dr. akka diodes the
American ones
alligators prairie dogs just ridiculous
bugs and animals everywhere I think it
makes me at peace with myself I guess a
quiet place to ask yourself questions
and maybe you need to ask yourself
spiritual place for inner reflection as
well as recreation seeing in all
directions around you I just like I've
become a lot less stressed about life
period it's basically just like yeah set
aside land that they just found the
raddest land and they're like we're
keeping this one because this is the
coolest one we've usually been the
youngest people it's definitely the
older crowd that's still here
people who have been dirt bagging it
before I was born so we do get a lot of
youth from places like China sometimes
even France Germany that come here and
they usually seem pretty excited